sometimes when we talk about biden like
will he run for re-election what i
actually think has happened is he's
gonna forget that he was told he wasn't
so he's gonna announce that he is and
how it's gonna have to be he's gonna he
said that he was going to he's gonna
forget that he's president and there's
gonna be like remember when he announced
he was running for the senate while he
was running for president yeah and
hasn't he called both hasn't he called
jill biden or his wife the president at
one point several times he kept calling
her the president several times and he
and he introduced his sister as his wife
yeah but he's the dude's got to be on
some kind of pills like i bet they're
giving him all this crazy iv therapy
stuff they're putting them in hyperbaric
like regeneration chambers they're like
we must but what's gonna happen is come
2024 he's gonna be like what am i what
am i doing and they're like you're
retired it's like oh
and then they're gonna walk out be
buddha judge your new son and be like
come on get in there right and then
they're gonna yeah or aoc yeah i hope so
i really hope it's aoc she is so dumb
though you guys
i mean maybe ignorance you know libby's
letting us in on a secret yeah still
learning i don't think that she's
ignorant i think she's i think she's
just not that bright really yeah she
strikes me as in every time she speaks
about things she strikes you as a
television have you ever watched she
puts her glasses on and she looks she
sits up straight like it's good it's a
good move maybe she's just maybe it's
more charisma than intelligence she's
got she's got spunk yeah she's she's so
new i mean she says stuff that isn't
true like that's right so that's more
ignorance like if she doesn't know stuff
that's no it's stupid it is i think was
it sheamus who said it was a total chad
move when she went on colbert just made
up stuff about this
crazy i mean that's that's ballsy you
know so the thing about aoc is that i
kind of view her similarly similarly to
trump and that it would be like chaotic
for the deep state and i'm down for that
it's not my preferred candidate
but if you if it was aoc versus trump
i'm kind of like whoever wins the stat
that the bureaucratic state is going to
be crying into their pillow tonight do
you think would win
i think trump would win but trump would
win over i do think aoc is the democrats
best choice like their best bet she's
got name recognition she's young
she's like she's got 13 million
followers not the most prominent
particularly prominent but gavin newsom
he's like a he's like plastic he's a
he's generic one of the things they've
been saying they don't want you know
yeah he's just like an established
white kind of you know he's younger than
let's say bernie sanders but one thing
he definitely has against him is a lot
of data to back up why he sucks
you know his schools are failing his
state is failing
he's an abortion sanctuary state
he constantly brings back coveted
regulations he's an immigrant um
illegal immigrant sanctuary state right
he's an immigrant no yeah i did but
that's because i left out words
yeah yeah i understand um he messed he
like violated all his own cove
restrictions remember those like no
one's gonna forget those dinners at
i think if aoc were to get elected
her whole thing is like attention social
media saying whatever it would be pure
it would be pandemonium
just just insanity in the white house
they would be coming to her being like
uh president ocasio-cortez here are the
here's the documents on the latest
problem that's happening in afghanistan
and then she's going to say something
totally unrelated or relevant she's
gonna be like you know when we went into
afghanistan in 2005 in desert storm the
first time you had saddam hussein who
was working with isis and you know
that's why i don't think it's a good
idea and they're going to be like she's
just saying random things related to the
middle east either that or yeah either
that or she'll just be like we can't go
to war with that country because that
would be racist
wait i'll take it yeah you know it's
like no more troops in the middle east
because president aoc says it's settler
colonialism i'll be like okay
all right like no foreign incursions
i don't care the reason i mean i i'm
kind of worried about that at the
federal level and then the weirdly
isolationist because she's like no we
just have to leave everyone else alone
and then the first gentleman will be a
guy with the paige on foot wiki right
like
the redhead dude yeah why he does well
they i don't know for sure but remember
they were going after his feet when he
wore sandals when they went to florida
to flout covered restrictions and have a
good time
so that was you just want to date me
that was like her right
that was her whole thing and it was all
like and her boyfriend was sitting there
with yeah just i'm just imagining she's
like sitting down with kim jong-un and
he's like you know kim jong-un says
something about we have to negotiate
terms if i'm going to stop these nuclear
tests and she goes stop trying to date
me sir and then he's just like
what do i say it's almost as crazy as
trump
so like the americans have put a crazy
person in the white house again
yeah i don't know what she wants but
they couldn't they can't now we
zag the other way with crazy like it's
different kind of crazy they can't
figure that one out either i mean that
is kind of funny it's like trump is
aggressive arrogant kind of crazy and
she's like
woman kind of crazy they're also
arrogant kind of crazy but like that you
want to date me line it's like trump
would never say something like that like
i don't think a dude would be like
kim jong-un was trying to date me like
he wouldn't say i also think she knows
like it's a very awkward thing for most
men to respond to like they can say no
but also like why are you making this
about romance like we're professional
rivals like we're in politics like why
are you bringing this up like it's very
strange women women can make everything
about romance
yeah i mean it's a type of romance you
could say he only said that because
you've never heard about no that's not
i highly i would love to see cortez over
trump because of the youth it's the
youth over trump over trump i can't take
80 year olds in in office anymore man
they're right i'm not trying to be
ageist but it is really frustrating to
see
uh our parents or my parents generation
just refuse to give up power you know
they're just sitting there on piles of
cash and piles of power and they refuse
to clear the way for somebody else and
it's their fault it's and all of the
mess is their fault and it's like you
know we definitely need new people in
in washington this is one thing i like
about desantis like he's young he's like
you know isn't he gen x basically
i don't know
i think he's i think he's like 45 he's
like low end he's like let's say at most
50 he's got young children he hasn't
gone he's in his four years
that's awesome wow right so let's go get
it desantis over aoc if we could i'd
like to see the debate i'll be honest
that's something to my jury's out for me
on that but i would love to tell you
guys
a trump aoc debate would be the funniest
show i've ever seen good
and they'd keep doing it amazing excuse
me excuse me young lady no no crazy aoc
and then she'd be like trump just likes
me he thinks i'm hot it would just be
the weirdest thing
stephen stephen fry should be the
moderator of that debate can we really
i want to reach out to asu's people like
would you do it put it on your vision
for trump yeah even if you're going to
make a vision board of trump debating
aoc and then we're going to try and make
it happen wish it into reality several
years ago i was on twitter that was like
after trump is done with politics like
he should just and like when the next
presidential debates happen he should
just livestream him commenting on them
because it's probably more interesting
because like him watching him debate is
so bizarre
like i i there's nothing that compares
to it really bringing aoc into it like
we're sitting here talking about like
how funny it would be for aoc to like
debate or haven't have like a show like
being on a show with trump and then
imagining how it would backfire and
sort of backfire on us and that they end
up agreeing on tons of populist
positions and then like trump runs with
aoc as vp
he's like we're going to win everyone
she's like i was wrong about this man
we're going to get the union working
class manufacturing back it'll never
happen because it's not really the case
but
i'm gonna i'm gonna it would be nice to
get manufacturing back yeah yeah i mean
it was happening under trump yeah i'll
say this i
i will say with certainty
i believe donald trump would absolutely
do a sit down with aoc 100 probably and
i don't think ratings would be great and
she loves ratings you know yeah she had
nothing to lose she wouldn't do it
that'd be a good combo they don't even
have to agree or disagree they just talk
about it you don't think she'd do it i
don't think so i think we should i think
we should reach out there's only one way
for us to find out tim has to reach out
i expect you to be on twitter tonight
you know we've got
some of uh
trump's like inner circle's been on the
show yeah so we'll ask them
because they've told us like you know we
could arrange a sit down with donald
trump but it means we have to go to him
and it certainly would not be a two and
a half hour show but that's you know i
was saying like we'll have trump on as
long as he wants to be on it would be an
honor and a privilege and then just
whenever he's done we can shake his hand
and say thanks for coming and then you
know carry around the show like we do
normally we had joe rogan
did it yeah for like an hour he was on
longer than i thought he was gonna use
he said he could pop in for a few
minutes he hung out for like an hour i'd
be totally down i just
i mean if it's up in new jersey i mean
maybe aoc could come down and do it you
know maybe we do it at a venue or
something where it's like kind of you
know her security can bring her in and
make sure she's safe and trump's people
i don't know if they i don't know if
he'd want to go to a venue though he'd
be like pull the chairs up to where i'm
at
it would be the coolest thing in the
world though to be honest with you bring
them here it's a neutral ground they can
all have their security it'll be never
going to happen
yes but i can dream he's got that the
golf course in new jersey doesn't he so
this is what we were told is basically
we'd have to go up to bedminster sure to
uh if we were to do anything with trump
and then like is aoc going to drive down
there or whatever it's like that's not
that far
i mean like i'll tell you i don't think
uh
the one person that i know would
probably just say yes outright is vosh
if i if we hit him up we were like would
you like to sit down donald trump he'd
be like yes please
just and you know so i'll give him
credit for be willing to do that despite
the things we disagree on i don't think
there's very many leftists at all that
would actually sit down and and have
like a calm reasoned debate and you know
what's crazy about that is that
i mean trump was an anti-war president
right like the democrats for a long time
talked about being anti-war it's clear
that they're not obviously you know as
they court conflict with china and
russia at the same time
because that's apparently brilliant
diplomacy um
but yeah i don't so many of trump's
positions
like
well mostly just the anti-war one but
that's a classical position you can you
can you can criticize him a lot for
potty mouth stuff
decorum whatever but his foreign policy
stuff was the best i have ever seen in
my lifetime i thought the bilateral
agreement thing was smart and i also
another another leftist position of his
or her liberal position of his is to
have union manufacturing in the u.s to
keep things local to keep americans
employed to keep ourselves
self-sufficient these used to be liberal
positions yeah yeah they used to be and
then donald trump ran as a conservative
he supported gay marriage before getting
into office and i think he broke the
left because they were like what do we
campaign on now
he's
he went middle of the road vox.com in
2015 i think it was 2015 or 60 and said
donald trump's a moderate he's he's a
moderate candidate now it's really funny
to see that if you go back and look it
up because i'm like the media called him
worse than hitler yeah right but back
then they're like he's a moderate he was
moderate in policy but extreme in
personality and that was something they
couldn't look past well and really he's
like sort of a working-class hero
their decision-making is based on
emotion
that's that's that's simply put so when
donald trump gets up there and he goes
you know like oh you know fat pig or you
know only rosie o'donnell they're like
and everyone else is just like
and a lot of people are just like oh
geez
okay but but do the right thing with
with the border okay how about that
that's the thing too about carrie lake
i think
you got she's even got biden basically
bending the knee onto this policy biden
is going to be repairing gaps in the
border and like humans
look man
that's why i'm like why haven't they
called it for carrie lake because if
even joe biden agrees on the policy that
the arizona board is in trouble
that carrie lake's like whole thing is
like we gotta fix the border or one of
our big things well joe biden just
started re started rebuilding a border
wall yeah right he's he's building a
wall but he was like they and what was
that uh cringe on pierre was like it's
not trump's border wall we're just doing
what's necessary oh okay
but there was a building a wall there
was a democrat when you when you saw all
the coverage of the yuma stuff come out
at least my experience uh it was saying
you know this was a sector that had
previous funding but joe biden repealed
it and now he's gonna fix these gaps and
basically
there was one i can't remember his name
i have to look it up a democratic
arizona i think congressman who was like
i i just spoke to
uh president joe biden about this two
weeks ago and we're really going to fix
it now and he is running for reelection
right now like it is clear to everyone
that the border is out of control thanks
for checking out this segment from the
tim cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8 p.m and if
you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm we'll see you all there
you